[Music]
there's so many things I hope to see in
the Academy in Museum I want the public
to come and find out how many people it
takes to make a film it's about time
that we have a space that honors cinema
the history of cinema the forward
thinking and imagination toward the
future of cinema the next generation of
storytellers I'm really excited to learn
I feel like it's gonna be profoundly
educational and profoundly inspiring to
what I feel is possible in the future
we take for granted the animations the
special effects that exist today and we
don't realize all the science and the
engineering and everything that goes
behind it we all need good stories and
so I think this is a good place to
celebrate it I hope that independent
films you know are represented because I
think that's sort of the pioneer voices
are their dresses movies are rich
because of the history behind them and I
think for young filmmakers it's a way to
connect with what is the past of our
media it's the history of everything
just to go through that eras and eras of
cinema and film I am especially excited
to see women being celebrated I want to
see all the strong women that were the
foundation of our industry I hope to see
programming that like acknowledges the
women's names that we don't know women
like madeline anderson women like news
on palsy that all kind of contribute to
the craft of filmmaking a focus on all
the women that have contributed to
creating stories and telling stories and
obviously we want more every day but
hopefully we can honor the people who
have done it already
I am so excited that we are having a
movie Museum that's going to look at the
history of movies and it's going to go
across all the crafts it's going to look
at directing it's gonna look at sounds
gonna look at acting I think that's
really important and I love that we're
going to be going through the history of
movies but we're also going to be doing
a correction then we're going to go in
we're actually going to tell the stories
that have been lost and we're not
hold and that's what the museum's going
to do it's going to tell the story of
stories